as if we needed more evidence that
arming teachers is a bad idea a teacher
this week was arrested in Georgia after
barricading himself in a classroom and
firing a gun in school now common sense
tells us gun safety research tells us
educational knowledge tells us that
arming teachers is a really bad idea but
we also now have anecdotal evidence and
yes anecdotal evidence is one of the
weakest forms of evidence but it happens
to be corroborated evidence in this case
in addition to everything else that we
already know about this a 53 year old
male teacher in a Georgia high school
barricaded himself in a classroom fired
a handgun held a 30 to 45 minutes
standoff with police and yeah eventually
he was arrested he didn't seem to want
to hurt students he fired the gun at an
external window and exterior window as
it's described when the school's
principal tried to get into the
classroom that he had barricaded and of
course when I read this my reaction was
the students need to be armed
immediately armed all students so that
they can defend themselves against
teachers like this or maybe we need more
teachers with guns like if the principal
had been armed instead of failing to get
into the barricaded classroom he would
have I don't know shot the lock off the
door and pushed his way in or something
like that now truthfully fortunately
this was a minor incident right the only
injury in this entire thing I guess a
student was running away from the
classroom that this guy barricaded
himself in and like sprained their ankle
that's that's okay we can be glad about
that but we went through the scenarios
last week about arming teachers you arm
teachers and now you can have teachers
accidentally shooting students you can
have a teacher losing it and going after
students or other teachers because
they're disgruntled or for whatever
other reason you'll have lawsuits
against schools for students that were
wrongfully shot by teachers you'll have
police showing up in the midst of a
chaotic situation they'll see a teacher
with a gun and they don't know is the
teacher with the gun the good human with
a gun or the bad human with a gun and
shooting the teachers it has disaster
written all over it yeah I think it's
conceivable that a teacher could stop a
mass shoot
or school that could happen but I think
that the concerns that you just raised
far outweigh that possibility well and
the right the the red pill right as I'm
calling them on the internet they're
saying the teacher shooting a gun is a
false flag conspiracy meant to discredit
Trump's idea of arming teachers and once
again doesn't anybody think that if you
were going to orchestrate a false flag
to make arming teachers appear to be a
bad idea wouldn't they at least shoot
another student if not kill another
student why would you do if you're gonna
set up a false flag school shooting by a
teacher to try to discredit Trump's idea
of arming teachers you're not gonna go
through all that trouble trouble and
then have the guy just fired an external
window and give himself up to police I
just think that in a country of what 320
million people yeah this sort of thing
happens from time to time
oh yeah so we're only focusing on it now
because it's so newsworthy of our recent
mass shooting and back to the story
about we should cover these conspiracy
theories the audience was kind of mixed
and the common opinion was cover it but
don't go through like a long debunking
so that's what I did today I'm telling
you the red pill right says this was a
false flag to discredit Trump it's
patently absurd and makes no sense
whatsoever join us in our discussion of
all of the topics on today's show at
david pakman.com slash read it we will
take a break and be back after this
today's program is made possible in part
by futur vittor is a social forecasting
game where you compete with other
players to predict the future and it's
built on the principles of what's called
a prediction market a scientifically
proven way of using the wisdom of the
crowd to create more accurate
predictions about future events
prediction markets have been shown to
work much better than other forecasting
methods like polling or expert analysis
in many cases and futur has actually
taken the concept and turned it into a
fun easy to use social game you open up
the futur app and you'll see a whole
range of forecasts covering topics
across the board from politics to sports
and everything in between you can check
out my predictions and follow me to get
updates on my
profile which is linked to in the
description if you're watching this on
YouTube the tour is a great tool to find
out more about the world improve your
forecasting ability show off your
prediction skills to friends and even
better when you make predictions on
futur you're helping to create more
accurate forecasts for everybody their
mission of creating better predictions
is great and actually going in there and
seeing how well you can do at predicting
the future can be kind of addicting go
to futur com sign up and start making
forecast it's free and it's available on
both Android and iOS as well as on web
browsers and that's f you t you you are
calm